You've seen some interesting interfaces with drawable and likeable, but let me
give you another very common reason why people like to use interfaces. And that
is to be able to reuse an algorithm. Consider a common algorithm to compute an
average. Here I have an array of countries, each of which has a name and an
area. And I want to know, what is the average area of all of these countries.
Now of course, I could write a loop to compute that, but let's say I want to a
method that does this for any set of countries. So, I'd like you to complete
this method that takes an array of countries. For each of them, find out what
the area is simply by calling the Get Area method. Add up all those areas, and
then return the average.